apple is infamous for being the premium
tech company with insanely thick profit
margins well they eliminated their
cheapest phone this year and sold an
even more expensive and bigger one many
would compare apple to designer brands
like gucci and louis vuitton that have
gross margins well over 50 percent and
when you see products like a 1 000
monitor stand and 700 apple wheels it's
not surprising that apple has such an
image
but in reality apple has some of the
lowest margins in the tech industry
now don't get me wrong here apple still
makes boatloads of money with annual
earnings of
111.85 billion dollars which is the
third highest in the world
but the thing to keep in mind is that
apple also has revenue to match coming
in at 365 billion dollars per year which
is the fourth highest in the world in
terms of margin though apple's net
margin has sovereign at just above 20
percent for most of the past decade and
it was until the past 12 months that it
uptake to 25 mostly due to their
services
on the other hand google has a margin of
nvidia has an at margin of 32
facebook has an at margin of 36 and
microsoft has an ad margin of 38.5
and none of these guys hold a candle to
visa who boasts in that margin of 51
yet the only company that gets hate for
overpricing their products is apple
so here's how much apple actually makes
from their products and why their
overpriced brand image is really all
just marketing
the number one reason apple doesn't have
net margins as high as the other top
tech companies is because they're the
only ones that are mostly a hardware
business they're the only ones that have
to design a physical product source
materials work with manufacturers
package their products run physical
apple stores work with retailers ship
their products and so on and so forth i
don't think i need to explain why
hardware businesses are far less
profitable than software businesses but
then how much exactly does apple make
from their iphones and macbooks
well luckily for us apple is a public
company meaning that they post all of
their financials on a quarterly basis
and if we take a look at their most
recent quarterly report we'll see that
apple pulled in 65 billion in revenue
out of this 38.9 billion was from
iphones 9.2 billion was from max 8.3
billion was from ipads and 8.8 billion
was from accessories and other devices
as you can see iphone sales account for
about 60 of apple's entire product
revenue and iphones are basically the
middle of the road in terms of price
so we'll base our analysis on the iphone
apple's most popular iphone every year
is likely the standard iphone this year
that happens to be the iphone 13 which
comes in at 800
with all of that out of the way let's
look at apple's first expense which is
the cost of sales cost of sales is the
amount of money apple has to spend to
produce their products
last quarter this came in at 42.79
billion dollars or 65.7 percent of their
product revenue normalizing this data to
the iphone 13 we get 526 dollars per
phone so if you're able to pick up an
iphone 13 for 200 off from a carrier or
retailer you're getting the phone for
pretty close to the cost of production
something else to keep in mind is that
cost of production isn't the only
expense
the next expense on this list is
research and development
last quarter r d came in at 5.772
billion but apple doesn't list how much
of this is for their products and how
much of this is for their services with
cost of sales 89 of the total cost of
sales went towards their products and
it's likely a similar case with r d
i think we'd agree that the vast
majority of apple's r d spent on
designing their products and designing
software that's directly linked to their
products like ios face id touch id and
so on so i think 89 is a reasonable
estimate but to estimate conservatively
we'll call it 75
this means that apple roughly spends
4.329 billion dollars per quarter on
product related r d
that works out to 6.6 percent of product
revenue or 53 dollars per iphone 13.
moving on we have selling general and
administrative expenses
this includes marketing the cost to run
their stores patents licenses and
basically everything else involved in
running apple last quarter this came out
to 5.616 billion dollars if we assume a
75.25 split between products and
services again we get 4.212 billion
dollars per quarter that works out to
6.5 of their product revenue and 52 per
iphone 13. and finally the last expense
we have is income taxes
last quarter apple paid 2.697 billion
dollars in income taxes for this
category we have to reverse our 7525
assumption given that apple services
business is much more profitable than
their products business the income tax
to the service-related revenue is a lot
higher than the income tax due to
product related revenue in terms of
percentages
so if we assume that only 25 percent of
apple's tax bills due to product related
profits we get 674 million dollars
as a proportion of their product related
revenue that's 1.07 or about eight
dollars for iphone 13. all of this works
out to a total of 639 dollars for iphone
13 leaving apple with 161 worth of
profit or almost exactly 20
if apple had priced the iphone 13 at 700
their net margin wouldn't even be 10
so from a business perspective i think
we'd agreed that 750 is really the
lowest they could have gone so 800 is
pretty fair in my opinion something else
to consider is that most of apple's
iphone lineup is actually cheaper than
the iphone 13. under the iphone 13 we
have the 13 mini the 12 the 12 mini the
11 and the sc
and all of these likely only having that
margin of 10 to 15
on the other end of the spectrum we have
the 13 pro and the 13 pro max and those
no doubt have a profit margin of 30 to
40 percent if not over 40
but only a very small number of
customers buy these products and they
know that they're paying a big premium
for the vast majority of iphone buyers
though it's really not that bad
something else to note is that the vast
majority of iphone buyers aren't
actually buying at retail prices through
the apple website
most people either trade in their phones
get a deal with their carrier wait for
discounts at retailers or buy older
generations
if you're buying smart it's the carrier
retailer or apple that's putting the 100
to 200 that goes to apple's bottom line
so the truth is the average consumer is
not overpaying for iphones
if that's the case though how are there
so many alternative options that are way
cheaper than apple's offerings
well the answer to this is twofold with
the first being alternative modes of
monetization
one of the most famous value smartphones
out there is google's pixel lineup the
google pixel 6 is comparable to the
iphone 13 but it comes in 200 cheaper at
according to our mat this would leave
google with a negative profit margin of
39.
so how could that be possible
well there's no secret to it google is
literally selling their phones for no
profit if not a loss
and while that might sound taboo it's
actually extremely popular within
consumer tech
one of the best examples is gaming
consoles in may of 2021 microsoft
straight up admitted that they're
selling xboxes at a loss with the xbox
and the pixel series the money is made
after the sale the vast majority of
google's profits still comes from
google.com and their number one goal
with their smartphones is to get you to
use google.com
now apple does have methods to monetize
users after the initial purchase as well
but the key difference is that they're
all voluntary they're not forced to buy
apple music or icloud and you never have
to purchase an app from the app store
with the pixel however unless you
actively avoid google services they're
gonna serve you ads they're gonna
collect your data and they're gonna make
money
now i'm not trying to get into the
morality of this or claim that one mode
of monetization is better than the other
all i'm trying to illustrate is that
with apple users have to actively choose
to spend more money for apple to make
more money but with google users have to
actively avoid google services for
google to not make money considering
this apple has to make their money up
front while many competitors don't
also for the record google does have a
higher net margin than apple so
technically you're overpaying more for a
pixel than an iphone it's just not out
of pocket
the other key reason that apple products
are oftentimes more expensive is because
they spend more money on all aspects of
their business starting with their
employees
now apple does manufacture their iphones
in china using extremely cheap labor so
it's not like apple is a saint but in
terms of white-collar workers apple pays
them extremely well the median
compensation at apple is 159 000
and that's actually weighed down by
retail employees and customer support if
we look at departments like business
development communications product
development sales and even hr the
average salaries are above 200 000
two of the biggest companies that
destroy apple in terms of value are
xiaomi and huawei but these companies
are based in china now these companies
may be excellent employers and they may
be paying way above average for chinese
standards i'm not familiar with chinese
standards so i can't tell but compared
to american standards the compensation
is extremely low at xiaomi for instance
a software engineer earns 216 000 won
while that might sound like a lot it's
actually only thirty three thousand
eight hundred dollars
now you wanna guess what apple pays
their software engineers the minimum
apple pays their software engineers is
162 000
and that number actually goes up to 758
000 probably for chief engineers i think
that's all that needs to be said about
employee compensation aside from higher
compensation apple has expenses that
many competitors completely avoid apple
has 515 stores around the world google
has one
also apple is the one that often
develops new technologies like
fingerprint readers face id and wireless
headphones of course they didn't create
these technologies but they are the ones
that created the form that we used today
competitors often just copy it from
apple which significantly reduces their
own r d costs
if this is all true then why in the
world does apple come out with brain
dead products like 700 apple wheels well
the answer is simple it's just marketing
how many people do you think actually
buy these ludicrous products the answer
is no one and apple is well aware of
that they don't stock these products at
their stores and if you order online it
takes forever to ship the pro stand for
example takes 15 to 17 days to ship to
my house the iphone 13 however which is
likely in way more demand can ship to my
house tomorrow for free you would think
that if i'm buying a 1 000 monitor stand
with a 90 profit margins i should get
like one hour delivery but instead it's
over two weeks because apple doesn't
give a crap about these products
these products are specifically designed
to create headlines and to get people to
meme about them and spread the word that
apple is a luxury status brand even
though they're not don't get me wrong
here apple makes outstanding products
but they're more like seiko than rolex
their marketing however would convince
you otherwise
so don't fall for the headlines
apple does not overprice the vast
majority of their products
the reason their products are more
expensive is because they have to make
their profit up front and their business
costs more to run at the end of the day
though they only take 10 to 20 to the
bottom line when it comes to their
consumer products do you guys still
think that apple products are overpriced
comment that down below also drop a like
if this video made you look at apple
differently and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one